- Let's dig up something from social media
sure to make you smile ear to ear.
This is what I'm liking.
(intro music)
When Silvia and her sister, Elba,
lost their catering jobs in 2020,
Sylvia turned to one of her
favorite things, baking.
For her niece's birthday,
she designed a cake that
artfully spoke to the times.
She crafted a toilet
paper roll to go on top.
Elba thought it was hilarious,
so she posted it for her
friends and family to see.
And at the time they had no
idea that that post would lead
to a new business here in LA
with enough customers that
they'd never have to
get new jobs. Amazing.
We have Sylvia and Elba
on the line right now.
"What's up, y'all?
(cheering and clapping)
Hi! So tell us about your business."
- After the post of the toilet paper cake,
people reached out to Sylvia
to make more cakes for them.
And at first it was the little orders
and then more and more and more
until we knew we have to open a business.
And then we opened El Mana-
- Postres.
- Wow!
And now we make cake together
and we have made about 700 cakes so far.
- With sculpted cake, they
can take 2 or 3 days to make.
We do dinosaurs, trucks, shoes, purses.
We make a lot of children's shoes.
These are the most popular.
We make a lot Dragon Ball Z, Chanel,
Cocomelon, baby shark,
whatever the customer as for.
- It's amazing. You guys are so talented.
Like, those pictures are
insane. They look real.
So wait, what's under the cloth?
What are you hiding?
- Oh! We have a surprise for you, Kelly.
- Okay.
- Yes!
- Yes! What! Oh my gosh. I kid you not,
literally my daughter, with my money,
she bought my son, he turned
five, and bought him a present.
It was a giant alligator, just like this.
Not a, you know.
They love alligators.
- And then we love to
surprise people, you know,
and then people want
to surprise their kids
and then the most important for us
is the happiness of the kids, you know?
So we have a surprise here.
Look at this, Kelly.
- Wait, what? Oh my gosh!
- Money.
- That's amazing!
(cheering and clapping)
Oh my god!
What an amazing idea! You
guys, you're so creative.
I am totally coming to
you for cakes for my kids.
Oh my God, thank you so
much, Sylvia and Elba.
Congratulations on all the success.
I'm liking your post right now,
and that's not all ladies,
our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen at the Kelly Clarkson Show,
likes to celebrate those
who create fearlessly,
just like you two.
So they'll be using their
FriXion Erasable Pen
to write you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(cheering and clapping)
Yeah!